Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my
existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings want or desires,
and may you my beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from
carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of
your divine will, that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests
of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary,
to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light,
so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers. Amen.
So we begin this evening with September the 23rd 1926. There's a lot of very good things to be
shared this evening. Louisa said, I was fusing all of myself in the holy divine volition with the
piercing in my soul of not having seen my Jesus. While trying to do my acts in his will, regardless
of how she feels, she actually does her acts. And that's a good headline for us that you don't do
it just when you feel like it. Since I did not feel him together with me, oh, I felt a piece of
myself being torn away. She's using very graphic language to let us know the depth of her pain.
So I felt my little poor existence being torn just shreds without Jesus. Now all of this will be
explained as we go on, because the pattern in these writings is that the Lord allows her to
experience something. She asks him to help her and he comes along and he explains what she's actually
experiencing. So she said, I felt my little poor existence being torn just shreds without Jesus.
And I prayed that he would have pity on me and come back quickly to my poor soul. Then after
much struggling, he came back, but so very afflicted because of human perfody. Now we need
to look at that word. The dictionary says that perfody means corrupt, deceitful, treacherous,
dishonest and double dealing. That's a lot. That's the way of the world.
So it seemed that nations upon nations were brawling among themselves to the point of preparing deposits
of weapons in order to fight against each other. So it's only 1926, they're only after World War
One, and they're already preparing for World War Two, just as we speak, they are preparing for World
War Three. And they want to prepare for unexpected things to make battles arise. So in other words,
they're cooking it up. What madness, what human blindness? It seems that they no longer have the
sight to see good order or harmony. They want chaos. Now, if this is so, then you know who is
actually reigning on the earth, the one who brings evil and disorder and chaos. They only seem to
have eyes to see evil. And this blindness make them go off their heads so they do crazy things.
So what she's talking about is politics without wisdom, without understanding, without knowledge,
without any communication with God. In other words, it's hell on earth. So we're going to expect a
bit of judgment after this. So in seeing him so afflicted because of this, I said to him,
my love, leave this sadness. You will give them light and they won't do it. They did, you know.
And if my pains are needed, I am ready as long as they all remain in peace. Now,
if Louisa is only prepared to suffer for them, so long as they all remain in peace,
her suffering is not necessary at all. That's what we're going to hear, because they've no
intention of remaining in peace. They're cooking up at the Second World War. And Jesus with dignity
and with severity told me, my daughter, I keep you for myself to form in you, the kingdom of my
supreme fiat, not for them. Okay, so God moves on with his plans, even if the human race is going
totally in the opposite direction, his will will be done on earth as it is in heaven,
no matter how long he has to wait, as he has told us in earlier volumes. But if you look at Jeremiah
2911, God's will is indicated to us in Jeremiah 2911. I know the plans I have in mind for you,
they are plans for peace and not disaster, reserving a future full of hope for you.
This future full of hope is the new era of divine holiness that the Lord is working with
Louisa to prepare for humanity, which is going exactly in the opposite direction.
So it seems that when human beings are at their worst, he prepares his best for them.
So that's not for them. I've made you suffer even too much despair in the world. But because
of their perfidy, the word is repeated a second time. And because it's repeated a second time,
you know, they're only ripe for judgment, because perfidy is, as I said, deceitful, treacherous,
dishonest, double dealing and corrupt. So therefore, that is ripe for judgment. So because of this,
they don't deserve that I make you suffer for them. In other words, they have their minds
made up as to where they're going, and what they're going to do. And they have completely
disregarded God's will in the process. And while he was saying this, it seemed that he was holding
an iron stick. This is a translation. And the translator didn't realize that Jesus was revealing
a very biblical thing to Louisa. It's the iron rod, or OG. And the iron rod is in Sam 29,
which predicts the coming of the Messiah very accurately. And you will rule them with an iron rod.
In Revelation 12, 5, also talking about Jesus said he will rule them with an iron rod. And in
Revelation 19, 15, when he returns in glory, he's ruling with an iron rod. And there's another
reference to it in Revelation 2, verses 26 to 27. Now, before we go any further, what is this iron
rod? The iron rod is the immutable, unchangeable will of God. It will not change just because human
beings are in rebellion and going in the opposite direction. The will of God is not going to suit
the human will. The human will is what needs to come round and surrender to the divine will.
So here you have the human will and the divine will in absolute contention with each other.
Therefore, the iron rod has to show its justice. But if the people are actually doing God's will
and living in God's will, the iron rod isn't actually needed. It becomes a shepherd's staff,
Sam 23, to protect his people and to guide them. But here it's the iron rod. So he was holding an
iron rod in his hands in the act of casting it over the creatures. In other words, the reason for
a chastisement is to try and bring God's will on earth because that's the only way the earth can
actually work. Louise said she was frightened and she wanted to relieve Jesus from his affliction.
And so she said to him, "Jesus my love, for now, that's at this moment. Let us occupy ourselves with
the kingdom of your will so that you may be relieved." In other words, take your eyes off the disaster
that's outside and let the two of us look beyond the mountain and see what the future is holding
for them. And what you and I are suffering and praying for for them. I know that giving you space
to let you speak about the divine will is your joy and your feast. Therefore, your acts flow,
watch this now, your acts flow within me so that with the light of your will, more than the sun,
they may invest all humanity. Now notice that Louise has put herself in the breach between the
judgment of God and the deserving chastisement of the human race. And she says, "Lord, let's take
this maneuver and then your acts will flow in me and through me to them and light will go out to
the others." Now that's our role of intersection for the human race. All of us in the divine will
have that. We must keep interceding for them and making up for them and all the rest of it.
So your acts will flow with me, they will flow within mine so that with the light of your will,
which is more than the sun, it will invest all humanity. And I may constitute myself act for each
act taught for each thought and I will enclose everything. I will take all of their acts as though
in my power and in order to do everything that they do not do for you. Here we are substituting
and making up for all the others. That this is intercession at its absolute best and we need to
take this as a headline for ourselves how to intercede for others. In this way, she said,
"You will find everything in me." And he has always said that if he finds the complete thing,
even in one person, one to one with him, that satisfies him and the rest of them can take as
much as they want. And therefore, as she said, "Your affliction will depart from your heart."
And Jesus condescending to my yearnings went around together with me and then told me,
"This is the power of praying in the divine will. My daughter, what power my will contains."
It penetrates everywhere as light. So here you have 1926, the nations are cooking up the Second
World War. There is chaos and there's disintegration, there's madness all over the place. And because
there is one person on the planet praying in the divine will, the light of God goes everywhere.
Now, you know from the very early volumes, volume one to four, that during the First World War,
the Lord allowed Louisa to pray and intercede for the soldiers that were out losing their lives
in the most atrocious manner. And here you see that if even one person prays in the divine will,
light will go to absolutely everyone who needs it. No matter what situation they're in, no matter
what religion they have, no matter what age they are or what circumstance they find themselves in.
And I just love this because very particularly those who are dying and who need help,
this light will go to them and it will be the thing that will take them safely across
the divide and into the eternal life. So this light, it penetrates everywhere it expands,
it gives itself to each act, it multiplies itself to infinity and while it does so many
thing and multiplies in each thing, it remains always itself, always one. As it is keeping all
of its acts without dispersing them, even one of them. Now that sounds a contradiction in terms,
but if you consider the greatness of God and the nuttiness of us as little creatures,
then even the remotest movement on the part of God will cover all of us.
Okay, so wonderful example there of intercession in the divine will. So in the next three paragraphs
of this message, we have what the translator calls the three planes of the will of God. Now
don't mix this up with the four stages of growing in the divine will. But these planes are three
historic stages. We've met them many, many times before. Okay, so there's really nothing new here.
I don't know why they want to call them planes. So it's three stages of development of the divine
will. So the first stage is Blessed Mother, her intercession for the coming of the Redeemer.
The second one is Jesus himself and everything he did. And the third one is Louisa. Okay, see my
daughter. The first plane done in my will in the name of and for all creatures was done by the
sovereign queen. Now notice in the name of all, it was a universal intercession looking for universal
blessings. And this is what he's explaining to Louisa. And what is experiencing in her affliction
will come out in the messages following this. So it's intercession for everyone. At the moment
Louisa doesn't realize that the pain she is suffering, she's actually suffering it for everybody,
but she will understand soon. Now our Blessed Mother obtained for all creatures the highest good of
making the long for Redeemer descend on the earth. So it's a universal blessing she was looking for
and received, one who acts for all and in the name of all and makes up for all Aaron's universal
goods that conserve everyone now universal. Nobody is left out. No country, no caste, no creed,
no color, no language, no anything. Everybody's included. They're all God's creatures. So the
second plane done in the Supreme will was done by my humanity, he said, I embraced everyone and
everything as if all were one. Now in the divine will, everything becomes one. I satisfied for all
that's past, present and future, every single soul that will ever walk this planet. I left
not even one act of even one person without constituting my act in it. Just think about it.
He has read on every single act of your life and mine and of the lives of everybody you know
and love and care for. He has read on them all. Why has he done it so that the glory, the love and
the adoration watch those three to my celestial father might be complete for each act of the creature.
So he has done our duty to God. Now let's look at this. First of all, the glory. The Bible says
the glory is the shekinah or the manifestation that God makes of himself. Okay. Secondly, God is love
and love is the perfect response to love. He says adoration as the third thing. That's terribly,
terribly important because it is possible for a slave to adore their king with absolutely no love
and with absolutely no care and not wanting the glory of this king at all. So the adoration is
third so that it's actually in the right place. So we have to put God's glory first because that
what we will be doing eternally is experiencing the manifested glory of God. But we will have learned
on earth that the perfect response to this is love. John 15 9, as the father has loved me,
so I have loved you. Let's stop for a second. The father loves Jesus infinitely, absolutely,
perfectly, eternally, unconditionally and all the other things you can say. That's the way Jesus
loves us. And then he says, and that is the way you are to love each other. Unconditionally,
eternally, absolutely, with total forgiveness. And no matter what you know about the other person,
Jesus knew the worst about all of us. And so this is an all-conquering love without borders.
And it's the only decent response that we can give to God. If you go to 1 Corinthians 13, 13,
having told us what love is, Paul says, these three are the three that last faith, hope and love,
and the greatest of these is love. And then he tells us in 1 Corinthians 14, 1, you must want love
more than anything else. So the adoration that is given to the Lord is an adoration coming out
of perfect love. That adoration is worthy of God's glory. And when that adoration coming out of
perfect love is done in the divine will, it really is worthy of God. So I just wanted to
let you appreciate why he would put adoration as third there, where you might presume it's first.
And this, he said, impatriated or I hate that word, interceded for the fruit of my coming upon
the earth. It earned salvation and sanctity for all. Now, in the first paragraph we heard of all
the disaster and chaos that's on the earth. Okay. If you have a King James version of the Bible or
another oldish version of the Bible, but not the Jerusalem Bible, they have a wonderful expression
in Psalm 29 verse two, worship the Lord in the beauty of holiness. Now the beauty of holiness
is that there is order and harmony in the person's life. And that order and that harmony is the
order and harmony of God's will. And God's will brings order and harmony into everything to do with
us, our intellects, our memories, our wills, our thinking, our speaking, our acting, everything.
And so will you look at someone that has this divine order actually expressed in everything
that they are and everything they do, you're looking at the beauty of holiness. And there is an
extraordinary attractiveness about it. Extraordinary attractiveness about it. You'll also find the
same expression in the King James version in one Chronicles 1629, speaking about the beauty
of holiness. And there is something about the chaos that's in the world today. Just look at women,
look at the way they dress and you will realize beauty is gone. Look at the way they behave and
you will realize that beauty is gone. But if everything comes back to the way God actually wants,
there will be an extraordinary harmony and peace on the earth. The peace can't be brought
about by political powers. They don't know what peace is because that peace is the individual
person coming right back into the center of God's will and God's life and grace and love flowing
through that person. That makes them extraordinarily attractive, extraordinarily attractive. And it's
nothing to do with physical stuff. That's nothing to do with painting your face. You can paint your
face over a very ugly face. But this beauty is deep within and it's very, very wonderful.
So Jesus said he prayed, he interceded that one day we would all come back to this.
I'd love you with now. And if many do not take it, he said, it's their fault. It's there for them.
Not the fault of the giver who is Jesus. Therefore my life interceded for universal goods for everyone.
I opened the gates of heaven for all. John 10, 7, I am the gate. John 14, 1, I have prepared a place
for you in heaven. It's all done. He has done the work. We understand that if we have gone to
enormous trouble to create something beautiful for another person and they just throw it back
in your face, we understand the insult that is involved. We understand the humiliation that is
involved and the enormous pain that you experience in that rejection. That's what Jesus is talking
about. That's why he came to Louisa. Absolutely distraught. So the third stage or the final stage
or the third plane of the development of the kingdom of the divine will is in Louisa. It will
be done by you, he said. And this is why everything you do, I make you act for all. Notice the I make
you do it. It's himself that's doing it. But he needs, he always wants cooperation from at least
one person on the earth when he's doing something. He wants somehow that the human race will tell
him that we're interested in what he's doing. I make you act for all, he said. I make you embrace
all that every soul from Adam to Zachary. And to make up in the name of each of their acts,
there's your substitution, reparation and everything else. Your plane must be equal to mine. Now he's
divine and Louisa is human, but the same divine will is inside of them and he can elevate her actions
because that's what living in the divine will is. And so all of her acts have got to be at a level
where they can move the divinity to do what they want to do. So your plane must be equal to mine.
It must be unified to that of the celestial empress. Okay. And this will serve to intercede
for the kingdom of the supreme fiat. And she's not alone. Our blessed mother has done all of this
before her. And Jesus has done all of this before her. And then her acts join that. And there is a
Trinity on earth as we've read in earlier volumes working to bring the human race to its perfection
of holiness. In other words, the price will have been paid. There's no excuse at all for us if we
don't receive it. Nothing must escape one who must do a universal good so as to bind all of humanity
bind to all of humanity, the good that she wants to give. In order to make up for all
the acts on in my will form double chains, but chains of light, which are the strongest,
the longest and not subject to breaking. No one will have the ability to break a chain of light.
It is more than a solar ray, which no one can shatter and even less bar its way to whatever place
and length and width of the ray wants to reach. And these chains of light bind God also to give
universal goods and the creature to receive them. And this is absolutely brilliant. Only God could
do it. He says, Louisa, what we're doing is that we are making something spiritual and people who
only understand something material won't even believe it's in existence. And so they cannot
actually block it. It's fantastic. It's chains of light. So they are unbreakable.
And no matter what anybody in the political sphere or the social sphere or the material sphere
wants to do to change this, they cannot do it. It's not subject to breaking. It is of the divine.
And so it's literally brilliant to see how the Lord gets around all the blocks that we give him.
And when we talk about light, the divine will is light. And we know from all the 20 volumes that
we have studied that the divine will wants to save every single soul that will come to this planet.
Wants every single one of them to reach the fullness. Wants every single one of them to reach heaven
and to reach the place in heaven that was actually designed for them. That God wants the absolute
highest and best for us. But he knows that the fall of the human race has made us very twisted
and that we have got caught up in all kinds of nets. And so light can break through a net.
When you pull down your curtains at night, you get up in the morning and the light has
actually managed to come round the curtain underneath and above and so on. The light gets in. It can
get round your block. And it's the fact that he has designed such a thing as to be able to get
round us and to get around all the blocks that we give him. I just give glory to him. I'd say you're
fantastic. I think it's brilliant. Just think about it. I just think it's really wonderful.
So let's go on to September the 26th, 1926. And this is beyond brilliant.
The mere word will of God. In English, we would say the mere expression will of God.
But you see, Jesus is speaking in biblical terms. And what we call the Ten Commandments
are actually called the Ten Words. A word is something that came forth from the Blessed Trinity
to give us life. The fact that we have to put three words into his one word to express it,
is just the problem of our language, that's all. So the mere word at will of God contains an eternal
tragedy, how everything converts into love and prayer. Now, this is utterly brilliant and
will show you exactly what prayer in the divine will is actually like. I put a VIP on this one.
And it's brilliant. So in the first paragraph, by right, by justice, everything belongs to the
divine will. But if you possess the divine will, you have a right to everything in heaven and on
earth. It's amazing. Louisa said, I was feeling all immersed in this supreme volition. And my poor
mind was thinking about the many admirable effects it produces. And my beloved Jesus told me,
my daughter, the mere word will of God contains an eternal portent, which no one can equal.
It is a word that embraces everything, including heaven and earth. This fiat contains the creative
font or source. And there's nothing good which cannot come from it. So one who possesses my will,
by virtue of that divine will, acquires by right all the goods that this fiat possesses. So I'm
going to count them for you. It's absolutely amazing. Therefore, she acquires number one,
the right to the likeness of her creator. That's Genesis 127, Romans A29. Secondly,
she acquires the right to divine sanctity, not just ordinary sanctity.
Number three, she acquires the right to his goodness. I mean, what else do you need?
Fourthly, she acquires the right to his love.
Then what's ecstasy? By right, heaven and earth are hers. Therefore, there's no purgatory.
Because all came into existence from this fiat. And with reason, her rights extend over everything.
So for her rights, I want to give Sam 37 verse 11 and Matthew five five. So the greatest gift,
the greatest grace I can give to you is to give you my will, because all possible imaginable goods
abound in it. I've read that for you rather than a creature somewhere else. And by right,
because everything belongs to it. It's just beyond brilliant. So I want to give you Ephesians 3,
14 to 21 that you will come eventually to the utter fullness of God.
Afterwards, Louisa said, my sweet Jesus made himself seen coming out from within my interior,
where the kingdom of God dwells. That's Luke 17 21 and one Corinthians 3 16. And he was looking
at me. He fixed his gaze on me so much as if he wanted to portray himself, as if he wanted to
engrave himself within my soul. Well, that's two Corinthians 3 18. You become like what you worship.
There's an expression on people's faces that actually tells you what religion they have.
There's an expression on people's faces that tell you whether love is in their lives or not.
If you only know what to look for, you can see it quite clearly. So Jesus wants to engrave himself
on her soul. On seeing this, she said to him, my love, Jesus, have pity on me. Don't you see how
ugly I am. Your privation during these last days has rendered me even uglier. I feel I'm good at
nothing. Even the realms in your will I do with difficulty. Oh, how bad I feel. Your privation,
what this is like a consuming fire for me. Now, we're going to get the explanation of this
and what she was experiencing at the beginning of September 23 in a minute. For the consuming fire,
I want to give you Hebrews 1229. Our God is a consuming fire. Okay. And this is burning everything
in me takes away from me the life of doing good. We would say the ability to do anything.
It leaves me only your adorable will, which binding me all to itself makes me want nothing,
but your fiat to see and touch nothing but your most holy will. Therefore, everything has been
taken from her. The stripping is complete. Louisa is in the same condition as someone who has passed
to the other side, because it is in the dying process that we are stripped absolutely of everything,
including our bodies, absolutely everything has to go. And here, everything has been stripped from
Louisa. Now, we go from here into a most extraordinary, wonderful description of praying in the divine
will put a VIP on this paragraph and write it out for yourself. It's really brilliant.
And it's a very good answer for people who think that they must be talking all the time that they're
praying. If I had to talk all the time I was praying, I'd give it up long since, because
while I teach an awful lot, I'm actually quite mute in my relationship with God. There's a lot of
looking and seeing and understanding, but without words. So Jesus resuming his teaching said,
"My daughter, wherever my will is present, everything underlying is sanctity. Everything is love
and everything is prayer." Now, we really need to look at this. So, since the source,
the fount, is in you, your thoughts, your gazes, your words, your heartbeat, and also your movement,
everything is love and prayer. That means you become prayer. Everything. It's not the form of
words that makes prayer very important. It's not the form of words. And you have that in Matthew
chapter 6 from verses 5 to 15. It's not saying long words to the Lord, even the most wonderful words.
It's not it. No, it is my operating will which dominating all of your being makes of your thoughts.
Now, it's He who is doing it in us. You desire it. I do it. Okay. Makes of your thought words,
gazes, heartbeats, and movements as many little fountains which spring up from the divine will.
And rising up to heaven in their mute language, not as mute. This is silence. This is contemplation.
Some pray, some love, some adore, some bless, etc. In some, my will makes the soul do what is holy
and makes the soul do what belongs to the divine being. Now, he's the only one who can enable us
to do this. Makes the soul means he enables us. He's working within us. And without him,
we could do nothing. John 15, 5, Philippians 4, 13, I can do all things in Christ who gives
me the strength. Without him, we can do absolutely nothing. Therefore, the soul who possesses the
supreme will as life. That means you have it. You're actually in your possession. It's the life
you're living is the true heaven, which be it even mute narrates the glory of God and announces
itself as the work of his creative hands. This is straight out of the Sam's. I want to give you Sam
19, verses one to four, where you're told that all of creation, even though it's mute, is glorifying
God continuously. This is a quotation also from Sam 29, which is telling us to glorify God in
everything. It's also a quotation from Deuteronomy 28, 12, Sam 90 verse 17 and Isaiah 64, 8.
We are the work of your hands. Actually, Sam 8 says, you created us with the tips of your fingers.
In other words, it took absolutely nothing to create us. So even if we are completely silent,
we've entered into this solitude. This is what's actually going on inside of us. I think it's
fantastic. How beautiful it is to see the soul in whom my will reigns. As she sinks, looks, speaks,
palpitates, breathes, moves, she makes the stars to adorn her heaven to narrate more the glory of
the one who created her. My will embraces everything as though in one breath and lets nothing of all
that is good and wholly escape the soul. Now you need to take that very, very slowly.
I've taken it word by word, phrased by phrase and made sure it just entered into me. It's just a
wonderful thing. So let's go to September the 28th, 1926. And Louisa is in trouble because of
the writings again. But a very interesting thing happens in paragraph one. Very interesting.
What do you do when it comes to revealing the king's secret? Louisa said I was feeling very
oppressed and as though crushed under the weight of a profound humiliation. Because I had been told
that not only of what regards the will of God must be printed, but also what regards the other
things that beloved Jesus had told me. My pain was such as to take away from me even the words,
to be able to say something so that they wouldn't do it. Nor was I able to pray my beloved Jesus
that he would not allow it. Everything was silence inside and outside of me. Let me give you that
in different language. She was stunned. Okay. Now why is she not reacting? Louisa is pretty
good at reacting. But if you remember back to September the 20th, 1926, which we had last week,
you'll realize that on the same subject of her writings, Louisa felt so embittered she actually
reacted. And Jesus told her that because she withdrew even for a second, that the whole of
creation and heaven and everything else went into convulsions. So now she knows she can't react.
It's fascinating. She can't react. And so she just keeps this stunned silence trying to hold herself
still in the divine will so that she won't shake the heavens and the earth. Because there's only one
will in heaven, one and that one will is in Louisa as well. And so it has this very, very powerful
effect. Everything was silenced, she said, inside of me and outside of me. And then beloved Jesus
moving in my interior, clasp me to himself to infuse in me courage and strength because after all
he knows what she's going through my daughter, he said, I don't want you to look at what you have
written as yours. But look at his mind. And there's something that doesn't belong to you. In other
words, can you step back from this? Can you detach from it? Now there's always something
for each one of us that can be quite difficult to step back from. It could be a relationship.
It could be a situation in the family. It could be something in yourself. It could be something
that you hold on to, but it can be quite difficult to step back from. And the solution is to step
back from it and allow the power of the divine will to come between you and that person or that
situation or whatever it is that's holding you stoned and in pain. I think it's a very good answer
to a lot of people who are suffering today because of persecution within the family over
having to be vaccinated and all that kind of stuff. I think it's a good answer. So you detach,
step back into the will of God, step back into the love of God and let God act for you. He will.
So he says, I want you to step back from it. Look at it as something that doesn't belong to you.
You must not enter into it at all. I will take care of everything. Now I think all of you should take
that sentence into all the crises that are coming in the years that are coming upon us. The crisis
is going to get worse and worse and worse. Please, please, please take that as God's answer.
Don't enter into it at all. Let him take care of everything. Therefore, I want you to entrust it
into my care. Put it whatever it is you're worried about a child, you're worried about your husband,
your wife, whoever it is, you're worried about the situation, whatever it is, put it all into
the divine hands. You're putting it into the hands of the Creator and the Redeemer and the
sanctifier, you can't put it into better hands. And you got to trust God beyond reason with it as
well. I want you to entrust it to my care. And as you write, I want you to give it to me as a gift.
So there you are with your problem. Whatever it is that's challenging you, hand it over to him as a
gift so that I may be free to do whatever I want in the situation is. And therefore, we want that
God will act in the situation, that God will touch the person you love, and that you may be left
only with what you need in order to live in my will. I've given you many precious gift and much
knowledge that I have manifested to you. He said, "Don't you want to give me anything?"
I love the way he gets round her and makes it easier for her to give him this thing that she
finds so difficult. So in the next paragraph then, Jesus is looking for a heroic surrender.
And in the years to come, he's looking for that, from us as well. Because Louisa has to be the
first triumph of the divine will, therefore she's got to surrender everything. And if we have to be
triumph in the divine will, we have to surrender everything as well. So Louisa said, "My Jesus
forgive me. I myself wouldn't want to feel what I feel. Thinking that what has passed between you
and me must be known by others makes me restless. That's very nicely poor. Absolute drives are
crazy. And it gives me such pain that I cannot explain. Therefore, give me strength. In you,
I abandon myself and I give everything to you. There's heroic surrender. And it's the heroic
surrender that absolutely overflows in grace for everybody else. And so if the Lord could bring her
to heroic surrender, he can bring us to it as well. God is not a respecter of persons. He has
revealed this material for you and me so that we will take this journey and reach this extraordinary
destination. As with Jesus said, "Good, my daughter. It is my glory and the triumph of my will that requires
all of this." But it wants, it demands, that its first triumph be over you. In other words,
she can't keep anything for herself. She must surrender everything. And surrendering our feelings
about things, surrender how we feel about our sons and daughters, our husbands and wives,
that we find very difficult. Surrendering how we feel about what the government is doing or not
doing or what anybody is doing or not doing. We can find that difficult, but we need to do it.
So don't worry about the feelings. Just say, "Lord, I surrender." The will is the driver of the train.
The feelings are all these wobbly carriages behind. And eventually, the wobbly carriages will stay on
track if the driver in front actually makes the good decision. So don't wait until you feel good
to surrender. Just say, "Lord, I surrender." Everything now. And that's it. I don't care what
I'm feeling because Louisa is suffering terribly when she's making this surrender to the Lord.
So he says that the divine will demands that its first triumph be in Louisa. Aren't you happy to
become the victory, the triumph of this supreme will? Do you not want then to make any sacrifice
to the supreme kingdom that it may be known and possessed by creatures? In other words,
Louisa, this is a very precious gift that you can give to me to bless the rest of the human race.
And if we could understand that putting our little gift, I always think of anything I have to give
to him as my drop of water in the wine of his love. And it's only a drop of water. It can be painful
for me or expensive for me, but it's nothing to him. But it does allow us to be participators,
and that's the very important thing. And so the complete stripping of the human will must happen.
Complete stripping. We can't have anything for ourselves. So Jesus said, "I do know that you suffer
very much in seeing that after long years of secrecy between me and you in which I have kept
you hidden with so much jealousy, so much jealousy that means he minded her hugely so that she would
be able to complete this journey without interference. Our secrets are now coming out. So you feel
strong impressions. We would say I have strong feelings about it. But when it is I that wanted,
he said, "You must want it as well." Now I've several times given you the statement of St. Therese,
"I choose Lord what you choose for me." That's very important when we come to difficult things.
Therefore, let us be in agreement and don't worry. So I want to give you Sam 25 verse 14,
Matthew 13 35 and Luke 8 17. So we now come to the final short paragraph in which the Reverend
Father is Annabelle de Francia, who was her extraordinary confessor at the time. Then after
this he made me see Annabelle de Francia and Jesus being near him placed his right hand on his head
to infuse in him steadiness. We would say firmness, help and will. Saying to him, "My son, hurry,
do not lose time. I will help you. I will be near you and that everything may go well and
according to my will." Just as I care that my will be known and just as I have dictated the
writings about the kingdom, he has said that so many times up to now that he himself is the author
of this material. But you know that by reading it anyway. Louisa never went to school. She couldn't
produce profound mystical theology like this. It's absolutely impossible. So Jesus is the author.
But you recognize the way he speaks if you've read any of the other mystics. So I have dictated
these writings about the kingdom of the Supreme Fiat with paternal goodness. So I will help with
the printing. Interesting, isn't it? I will be in the midst of those who will occupy themselves
with it so that everything may be regulated by me. So therefore hurry, hurry. Now we know that
initially St. Annabelle de Francia dealt with the first 10 volumes and he gave his imprimaturine
everything to the first 10 volumes. And then later he did 11 to 19 in his own lifetime.
Okay, we've only a few minutes left but I'm going to try the next one. October the second 1926.
How all the generations are linked to each other. As far as the Lord is concerned, he has won
mystical body and it doesn't really matter whether you lived in the 16th century or the 21st. You have
your position. And he's saying that one generation must pray and open the way for the next generation.
And that's very important for us because we're in the position of praying and interceding to open
the kingdom of the divine will for the next generations who appear to be showing no sign whatsoever
of any interest in it, which is really interesting. So Louisa said, I was feeling
embittered to the summit because of the privation of my sweet Jesus. All how bad I felt I couldn't
take anymore. But when I reached as though the extremes of pain, he moved in my interior. The
extremes of pain is that he's looking for total heroism from her because she's the one that he's
using to found this kingdom. He moved in my interior and all afflicted he said to me, my daughter,
I'm looking at how much I have to expand the boundaries of the kingdom of the divine will
to give possession of it to humanity. I know that they are unable to grasp the endlessness
of the kingdom of my divine will because it's not given to them as creatures to cross and embrace
a will that corresponds to a kingdom that has no boundaries. So because we're creatures, I mean,
there's stuff here that we can't really grasp unless the Lord actually puts it infused into us.
In fact, since they are created beings, they're always restricted and limited. And even though
they are limited, I dispose more or less goods and the extension of the expenses which they must
possess according to their dispositions. That is whether they are open to God, whether they're
willing to enter into relationship with God, whether they're willing to cooperate with God and so on.
And so I'm looking at posterity. Now this is 1926 and he's looking at our generation.
Okay, I'm looking at posterity. I'm looking at the dispositions that they will have. He's
talking about you and me now. And I'm looking at those in the present that's 1926 to see the
dispositions which they have because those in the present must pray, intercede and prepare the
kingdom of the supreme fear for posterity. So the people during Louisa's lifetime and afterwards
have actually done the intercession for us and we have to do the intercession for the people coming
after us. So we have to look after the posterity and according to the dispositions of posterity
enter the interest of those present. Do I keep expanding the boundaries of my kingdom? So since
the Lord saw all of us will be really interested, he prepared the way for us ahead of time. It's
fascinating because the generations are so linked to one another that it always happens this way.
One prays, another prepares, another impotrates, another possesses. So look at the mission of
Jesus. It's actually mentioned in the second half of John chapter four where Jesus explained that he
was reaping a harvest sown by the prophets before him in Samaria and that he was planting a harvest
in Samaria that the apostles were going to reap and the apostles would plant a harvest that the
next generation of missionaries would reap and that's the way it goes from generation to generation
because we're all the body of Christ and it's one part of the body taking care of the next one.
So in the next paragraph God's word is the greatest gift. Okay. The same happened for my coming upon
the earth in order to form redemption. It was not those who were present, that is the apostles and
the believers at the time when Jesus was preaching. I wasn't them that prayed and sighed and cried
to obtain its goods. They are the ones who enjoy them and possess them just like you and I enjoy
and possess the goods that were interceded for by the people before us. The ones who did that were
those who lived before my coming so you're talking about the saints of the Old Testament and according
to the dispositions of those in the present and the prayers and dispositions of those in the past,
so did I expand the boundaries of the goods of redemption. In fact, only when a good can be useful
for creatures do I give it. He said that many times up to now. But if it brings them no usefulness,
why would you give it? And this practical usefulness is taken by them if they have more dispositions,
they're more disposed. But you know when I expand its boundaries, when I manifest to you a new
knowledge that regards the kingdom of my will. So since the kingdom of the divine will is now
for you and me completely revealed in the 36 volumes, he has expanded the kingdom fully for us.
We can have as much as we want. So this is why before manifesting it to you,
I cast a glance over all that is people in the past and people in the future. I want to see their
dispositions. In other words, he wants to give the greatest gift of the human race and he wants to
know if the human race is actually interested in receiving it. That's why he looks at the past,
the present and the future. So I cast a glance over all to see their dispositions, whether it
will be useful for them or it will be for them as if I hadn't spoken. In other words, they will
disregard the gift. And in seeing that I want to expand my boundaries more in order to give them
more goods, more joys, more happiness to possess, but they're not disposed. I feel afflicted and
I wait for your prayers, for your rounds in my will, for your pains in order to dispose those
present as well as posterity. Now this is the explanation for the pain that Louisa was describing
in the first message tonight. That was September the 23rd. Going to explain why she's experiencing
this dreadful pain. If people are not disposed, she said, I feel afflicted and I wait for you,
she has to make reparation. And then I return to the new surprises of my manifestations about my
will. This is why I am afflicted when I do not speak to you, because my word is the greatest gift
it is a new creation. That's 2 Corinthians 5, 17 and Revelation 21, 5. That means when he speaks,
he creates. Go back to the book of Genesis chapter 1. "Vayomer Elohim" and God said,
no matter what he said, that thing came into being. He said, let there be light. He said, let there be
animals, let there be plants, let there be whatever, let there be man. It was his word that went forth
and created. It's very important. So his word is a new creation. And being unable, he said, to
issue it from myself, because creatures are not disposed to receive it, I feel within me the weight
of the gift I want to give. And unable to give it, I remain afflicted and taciturn, which is exactly
the way he was in our first reading tonight. "And my affliction grows even more in seeing you afflicted
because of me. If you knew how much I feel your sadness," he said, "how it all pours into my heart
because they are inseparable and a husband and wife who are close to each other, one can't be in
the depths of sadness without the other one feeling it. It's not possible. I want to give you Romans 5 17
there. "My will," he said, "brings it deep into my inmost heart," this is Louisa's suffering,
"because I do not have two wills. I only have one. And since it reigns in you as a consequence,
it brings your afflictions deep inside of me. Therefore, pray and let your flight be continuous
in the supreme fear that you may intercede that souls would dispose themselves and that I may return
and speak again." Now he's talking about 1926 when all of this dreadful stuff is going on politically
and socially and they're cooking up a second world war. And so looking for souls that would be disposed
would be quite difficult. So having said this, Jesus kept silent and Louisa remained more afflicted
than before. She felt all the way that Jesus felt because of the lack of the dispositions of souls.
She felt as if Jesus could no longer speak to her for now. But Jesus wanted to cheer her from her
affliction and also to cheer himself and he said, "My daughter, courage, do not think that anything
that passed between me and you, do you think everything will be known," he said, "I know,
no, my daughter. I will make known that which is necessary, that which regards the kingdom of
the supreme fear." Now all that's been made available to us are the 36 volumes, not only of Louisa's
private documents. You know from the early volumes in particular that she actually says,
"No, I'm putting that into the document for the priest." Or rather, I will be even more generous
compared to what souls will take of this kingdom of mine to give them free field in order to advance
more and more so as to let them expand their possession in the supreme fear that they may never
say enough. We have no place else to reach. Now he has told us elsewhere that love never says enough.
God never says enough when it's love and life and giving life and giving love. And he doesn't want
us to say, "I have enough." He wants us to actually keep going as far as is possible for a creature.
It's beautiful that he wants so much for us. "No, no," he said, "I will use such abundance
that people will always have something to take and always something to expand their journey.
But in spite of such abundance, not everyone will know our secrets. Just as not everyone knows
what passed between me and my mother. Only the great saints have even been able to touch on the
glories of Mary, for example. Very few saints. So not everyone knows what passed between me and
my mother in order to form the kingdom of redemption, the surprising graces and the innumerable favors.
They will know them in heaven where there are no secrets. While on earth they will have known
only what I gave for their good. But notice he gives in super abundance. There's much more
than we actually want. And that's the way I will do it with you," he said. "If I looked,
it was for those who want to come to live in the kingdom of my will, but for you,
for the little daughter of my will, for the one who has formed this kingdom together with me with
so much sacrifice, will my love ever be able to say enough? No. Would my love be able to deny my
word to you? No. Or not pour into you the continuous flow of my graces? No, I cannot my little daughter.
This is not the nature of my heart nor of my will, which contains a continuous act never
interrupted of giving. Now he's been telling us that for every volume that we have read.
He gives continuously. And he has said of us that it's more blessed to give than to receive.
So it's a continuous act. It's never interrupted and it's always of giving. And it gives always new
surprises to one who knows no other life but the life of my will. So for anyone who will get totally
serious about this and live the divine will genuinely 24, 7, 3, 6, 5, life is a continuous surprise.
"If you see me taciturn," he said, "it's not because of you. Because between me and you,
there's no need for words in order to understand one another. Here's the beauty of holiness and
here's the beauty of contemplation. It's just a look, a gaze, an understanding. To see each other,
he said, is to understand each other. I pour all of myself into you and you pour all of yourself
into me. That's union with God, that's sanctity. And in pouring myself, I pour new graces into you
and you take what is necessary for you. We can't take everything God gives too much.
Like if you pour water into a tiny container this size, when the container is full, it can't take
anymore. So I pour new graces into you and you take what is necessary for you. You must be the primary
cause in order to form the kingdom of the divine fiat. This will not be necessary for those who
don't have to live it. I haven't said that awfully clear for you, but all he is demanding and giving
to Louisa will neither be demanded nor given to anybody else because the work will have been done.
With you, it's not just about living in the divine will, but actually forming the divine will
and its kingdom. Therefore, your Jesus must abound very much with you to give you the raw materials
for the formation of a kingdom so holy. Everything is from him. Everything is about him. Okay,
Louisa couldn't possibly do anything by herself. None of us can. This happens also in the low world.
He gives an example of what setting up a kingdom is like. It happens in the low world, which is
earth, of course. If one wants to set up a kingdom, he has need of many means on many raw materials,
while one who must only form one city needs an awful lot less or one who moves in just to live
in it with very few means they can live in the city. The sacrifices that one has to make in forming
the kingdom are not necessary for those who just come to live in the place. And you see,
we're coming along just to live in it. We're not actually forming it. So all that had to be done
to Louisa and for Louisa and all the gifts that had been given to her are actually not necessary
for us. But what is necessary for us is given to us with super abundance, as he said. Therefore,
I just want you to work in the formation of the kingdom of the supreme fiat and your Jesus will
take care of the rest. So that's our banquet for tonight. Thank you for listening. God bless.